and we're live
okay so today we're going to have a
surprise it's sitting right behind
him oh yeah okay it's very loud there's
only a few of them in america a few in
the world it's sold out within the first
hour when they announced that it's the
first ever
and i'm gonna show it i'm gonna show it
when we crack 3 000 people live
i'm going to show it to them i haven't
even turned around yet you've seen it
you haven't had to write on it like you
had with adrian that's a different story
but it's sitting right behind us
you know what uh first of all tom how
you doing
should we just tease him with the sound
what it sounds like should i just go
turn it on and see what the neighbors
are gonna
say yes hang it tight hang tight for me
hang tight for me hang on
all right let's see if we can do this
now is this dangerous for us because we
have microphones
gonna be like tint all right let's see
ready
okay so there's a little bit was that a
monster truck what was that pat
bicycle is that like yeah i was thinking
riding lawn mower huh
writing lawnmower writing lawnmower so
that's what it sounds like but when you
see it
yeah you said it looks like something
joker would drink yeah it did
uh-huh either joke or the batman one of
these two characters in here
so we got a surprise and by the way i'm
going to reveal it when we crack 3 000
okay
when it cracks three thousand live i'm
gonna show all right let's park down
back then we'll get right you smell
that's good too
within 20 minutes we're gonna be high
you may want to open that door right
there for the smell to get out because
we can smell the fumes
now we're talking that's my kind of part
we got lots
of great great topics to get into
i know you just had a friend's car that
was on
turning on fire but we'll get into that
here in a minute let me just say some of
the stories we got to cover today and
the first thing i want to do
is your story so united airlines hits
back at pilot training
diversity criticism they announced that
they're going to be hiring 50
over the next they'll you know next 50
whatever timeline it is 50
of the folks they hire is going to be
from a inclusive diversity community oh
thank god
so we're going to talk about now adam's
very happy about that china hits alibaba
with a record-breaking
2.8 billion dollar final behaving like a
monopoly coinbase is
on fire the ipo they're saying the value
of coinbase today
ready for this is bigger than goldman
sachs we're going to talk about that
amazon defeats historic alabama union
effort americans invested more in the
past five months than they did in the
last 12 months
domino's launching autonomous pizza
delivery with a tiny
self-driving car called r2 not d2 just
r2 they'd love to see it uh ever given
ship forbidden to leave the suez canal
until its owner pays up to a billion
dollars in compensation for the chaos it
cost
apple reportedly uh building new apple
tv with built-in camera and speaker
facebook spent 23 million dollars last
year on zuck security just in 2020
southwest airline recalling 2.7 2700
flight attendants
for summer travel company execs meet at
white house over chip
shortage opposition wins election and
greenland casting doubt on future of
earth rare earth mine ceo pay search
in a year of upheaval and leadership
challenges
china with a 400 billion dollar deal
with iran could deepen influence on the
middle east a topic we're definitely
touching today 46 percent want dwayne
the rock johnson as president as he
floats potential idea
2.1 billion dollars of undocumented
workers signal new york's progressive
shift
new york raises income tax on super
wealthy raising concerns among
corporations new york's wealthiest look
for
exit as the state readies hefty
tax increase and a couple other things
we got here is the
spending package army israeli army chief
appears to hint at possible role in iran
nuclear site incident
why run the sanctions 2024 stock is
rising
and then a couple last topics here don't
forget about the snoop and the code
brothers i got i got may talk about a
zoom call with snoop
uh and koch brothers somehow led to them
starting a pro wheat group
go figure anyways so tell us what
happened with your friend in california
well good to see you guys you know uh
have you heard
better ladies and gentlemen have you
heard that now get this work with me on
this
in california there's a problem where
there's homeless people have you heard
about this yes
it's out of control you know what else i
heard about this too you know why it's
so bad in california and this is this is
very serious is because other states
are giving their homeless population a
bus voucher
and a food valve and a one-way ticket to
california so that's part of the problem
too
so i was i saw my friend in west
hollywood on saturday and he was talking
about the fact that he had to get a new
car and we were going to introduce him
to one of our friends hey you know go
see this guy great guy he'll take care
of you by the way why do you need a new
car
and it came up well my car started on
fire
so then i was thinking maybe he had a
defective car a lemon something bad
happened something weird an electrical
spark he's telling us this just by the
way
and this is now we were at a store um in
west hollywood on los cienegas so this
is a very very you know you know the
area it's a very very popular area it's
very
high traffic it's very busy during the
day
so he tells us that the reason he needs
a new car is because a homeless person
started his car on
fire there was a homeless or now there's
a lot of homeless people around there
right there on the
homeless person started his car on fire
in the middle of the day what's the
motive what's the road
just because just because he was walking
down the street and tried to light the
light pole in front of their store on
fire but that was metal
so he wasn't able to do that so he took
the
the lighter and he lit the car this is
not uncommon by the way
this type of thing is this middle east
or is this la
it's crazy and then he he said he hit
l.a no
and he's talking about that i was
thinking man that's kind of crazy man i
wonder what that looked like the dude
actually had a video because the thing
was on fire
you have a video of this yeah there's
actually video guys
it looks like a movie set you got this
that's your friend's car what is that a
range rover what is that
it was some sort of suv and that's la
cienega that looks like a porsche
the suv oh damn isn't that crazy
yeah that's in front of his store yeah
literally the store is right there by
the yellow and then that right down
there by the way right across the street
there's a you know one of the most
popular restaurants in la is a
restaurant called catch
la yeah you know the fish on melrose
they're opening up a catch steak right
there across the street but they can't
open it
because there's a homeless encampment
because there's one patch of grass
that is city property right public
property so then they
they sent up an encampment there so the
restaurant can't even open so
you know when i found out too that other
states cold weather states are sending
people to california
and then no one even talks about doing
anything and slowly it gets worse and
worse and worse but that was just crazy
because it kind of hit close to home
knowing somebody that had his car
torched but he is going to get a new car
by the way
so so i got a by the way crazy story no
one
no one got hurt this kid nobody got hurt
which is good news it's a car a car
you can replace with insurance but
what's crazy is the fact that this is
happening right now regularly
in l.a and it's just part of the
lifestyle of living in l.a
what the homeless thing the burning the
cars the homelessness the looting that
can what are you going to do what are
you going to what are you going to get
from a homeless person that has nothing
go ahead and sue him what are you going
to get the state's going to give you
money the city's going to give you money
they're about to go bankrupt
so what are you really going to do to
this homeless person they're going to go
to jail
that's exactly what they want they want
a place to stay out with food and all
that other stuff hey let me light up
more cars to get a place to stay at so
i'm getting rewarded to lighting a car
on fire you're
giving me a place to live with food and
security
there is no safer place than prison go
to prison you got a bunch of security
people to protect you
and next when i say there's no safer
place than prison you're in a place
where you the only people you have to
worry about is what inmates
sure so here you go let me light up the
car i'm going to go to a place to live
and eat not so safe
yeah it is part of day-to-day life and
you almost become immune to it what you
see on a regular basis if you thought
this was 10 years ago you you wouldn't
believe that you were actually living
this life now you just think okay what's
next normal you just continue to accept
that
it's normal and by the way we talked
about this last week you weren't here
with us we
the total number of homelessness in in
america today is around 100 580 000
total homeless people in america today
five eighty out of accounted for right
yeah counted for out of 580 guess how
many live in california sixty percent
160. okay not 160 percent but 160
000 of the 160 000 60s in
and in the last 12 months it increased
by 20 000
homeless people just in the city
unbelievable and it's all invisible
areas too it's not like they're tucked
away in the forest or in the woods or
yeah somewhere in a vase so i got to
tell you something
kai can you pull up the tweet i got from
uh uh
somebody that's running for governor if
you go to my twitter account i told sam
i don't know if sam brought it up or not
go to my twitter account
and just type in patrickbetdavid go up
there so i get this tweet the other day
yeah click on that go down i retweet it
go down
yeah so not from the major so i get a
tweet uh
uh go a little bit lower go a little bit
lower maybe you should i thought i
retweeted it keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going it's that
far down
you've got to be kidding me that's a lot
of tweeting man is that the one
go up i think that's the one uh camera's
on the house says no that's not the one
anyways there was one tweet that came
out and i retweeted it
i'm surprised i can't find it anyways so
somebody
somebody shared the podcast remember the
podcast we did when i said the state of
california
needs to eliminate the state taxes and
the way you do it is what florida is
doing which is a tourist tax yeah
and california's got one of the biggest
amount of tourists that come in every
year and tourism is about to increase
how about you eliminate state taxes and
you impose a 15 percent
tourist tax for people that come so this
guy the video gets shared with them
wasn't he running for governor the video
gets shared with him apparently he is
running for governor
let me see if i can pull it up i want to
say his name is major am i wrong on that
i want to say
major uh will williams major
williams hang on let me just give him
credit because if he is
i want more people to look into here we
go i got it so kai it goes two days ago
it says someone listened to the podcast
good it's literally two days ago
so chris quintin shout out to him sends
this to me and he says
a california governor candidate major
williams is adopting patrick by david's
message on how to solve
kai this is you can't see it it's on the
11th
april 11th right there you don't see it
go a little lower
it'd be great if we can pull it up
interesting is it
well maybe why don't you go all the way
to the top that shows the tweets and
retweets like replies yeah tweets and
replies right there see if it comes up
there
go up uh 10 hours ago it should come up
here in a minute
two days ago okay well then it's not
showing up on your end
uh california governor uh candidate
major williams is adopting the patrick
bay david's message on how to solve
california taxes eliminate state income
tax and impose a tourist tax
unfortunately california legislate
legislators will vote for a tourist tax
on top of all the taxes including income
tax property
he put it on his website oh yeah we like
that i'd love to show this
kai i'm gonna send this to you and see
if you can figure out a way to put it up
because if this is the case i'd
encourage people to go look into him
yep it's time to think major for
governor
okay and he said economy taxes eliminate
state taxes
impose tourist tax of 15 percent this
model is viable and implemented by
states such as in florida our focus to
make sure that california
family small business independent
contractors are considered for financial
breaks
after disastrous year misguided
decisions from the leadership of the
state
our administration will execute the
regulatory uh other than statewide
so anyways there you go it's a great
idea yeah i'll tell you why because
if you actively promote the fact that we
want more
right you're going to bring them in it's
going to only help the economy that much
more the tourists are going to come in
the hotels are going to come back the
restaurants the beaches are going to get
cleaned up it's going to be great
it makes i love the fact that you know
it was something specific you didn't
just say hey raise taxes here you say 15
he can easily go run the numbers do the
math on what that means based on
average tourism in california matt that
might even revive san francisco help the
wine country
i mean all of california is a tourism
area i mean of course
and by the way here's what i the point i
made in the in the podcast couple weeks
when we talked about this here's what i
said
i said imagine a taurus is coming to the
state california
you want to go to san francisco napa you
want to go to san diego you want to go
to
hollywood palm springs pick it up you
got a million places to go to
for vacation in california you think the
cli the customer that's coming out as a
tourist is going to say no i'm not going
the difference between spending ten
thousand dollars versus eleven thousand
five hundred dollars hell no he's still
going to go
absolutely that's the point so what are
you doing i mean no one's like i'm not
gonna go to florida i'm not going to
south beach i'm not going to orlando yes
because of a tourist tax they're going
to pay it but the guy chris clinton who
the the guy that said unfortunately
california legislators will vote
here's a tough part with states like
california any time you
introduce a new tax they salivate over
it so if major williams if this is going
to be shared with you i want you to be
thinking about this and start talking
about it if this makes sense to you
is the following whenever you introduce
a new tax
what they do is they sit there in the
state of california places like
california new york illinois they sit
there and they say
huh great idea but we're definitely not
gonna eliminate
state taxes but guess what what if we
impose this
anyway five years from now ten years
from now so you
introduce a good idea they run with it
to add it on top
of everything else so you could say why
don't we add a gas tax
that's going to help us eliminate state
taxes and lower the state taxes top line
from what you got
from 13 points 13.3 let's just say with
obamacare all that stuff together
bring it down to six but rates let's
raise gas taxes
they'll say no let's do both of them so
you gotta figure out a way to
get the voter to understand the
difference between the two yeah and you
know what they
they've already spent the money they see
that fifteen percent they've always
figured out a way to say is your chair
keep going down
guys we got to switch same thing as last
time go okay and and you know so he's
got to get ready to figure out how to
debate caitlyn jenner over this because
she might be running for governor too
yeah it's going to be wide open in
california you know newsom is
pretty much fighting for his life right
now this recall thing is going to happen
now the difference is he's going to be
able to spend unlimited funds there's no
limit on what you can spend
so he's going to have 100 200 300
million dollars in a war chest to fight
this thing
we'll see but practical makes sense we
need a couple alternatives of people to
look at here
but i will tell you this shout out to a
guy like him who's running for governor
what this shows that he's listening it's
the biggest thing that you're listening
to what voters
in the state that you and i both love i
may be in florida but i love the state i
lived there for 20 some years
i'd love to see that state get their act
together i will say this too real
quickly is i think people are going to
vote for their
with their pocketbook in this recall
election forget about
the environment forgetting about all the
social issues that are out there
everybody in california has been
affected by this so ignore any polls you
hear that newsome might be okay
that 66 of people want to keep him in
there no one's going to admit it to a
pollster
ever i think he's got a real chance of
getting out well so when is this recall
election in california this fall
it's happening boom i mean they haven't
announced it officially but they've got
the signature so you're voting for
caitlyn jenner over newsom
i got to hear what she has to say if she
runs i think it'd be interesting
okay well you know she's going to bring
up the 72 olympics that's like the
cornerstone of the decathlon yeah 76
yeah 76.
you know you know i met him when he was
when it when he was uh uh
you met him before he was a her yeah i
mean i met him he and i have a picture
together
yeah from 20 years ago some man 19 years
yeah big hands big guy yeah totally if
you
appreciate athletics and you look at his
individual times and distances in all 10
events
the dude runs like a 10-500 right he
probably runs a 44
400 probably about a a 358
mile i mean it's in which is which is
ridiculous what you just said right
there ridiculous
greatest athlete of all time i met him
one time too i met her did you say
greatest athlete of all time well at
that time
at that time at that time he was the
greatest when you're the decathlon
champion you are the greatest athlete in
the world for that
you know i've spent a lot of time with
uh i know you have bruce jeff i know you
have and the only thing he would talk
about i mean this was during the whole
wedding and everything
he would only talk you know back in my
day when i was in the
76 uh the catholic did he really do this
all the time 2011 right now but
you know what he's earning that's all he
talks about that was like his whole
thing let me ask you a question yeah
what do you think tom brady is going to
be talking about 40 years from now of
course
what do you think what do you think
jordan talks about today the other day
matt sapolo was here he says i was
having a cigar when michael opened up
his restaurant and him and sheena go
there to sit down
he says we're sitting there for the
opening of his restaurant and guess who
comes and sits
to the left of sheena and he and sheena
have a cigar together
mike michael this is how long ago this
is like i don't know
a year ago so michael comes sits next to
sheena they're having cigar
and he says the entire time all michael
kept doing is taking shots at everybody
kept saying hey
you know somebody from the uh you know
the the chicago bears was there
what are you doing is the last biggest
milestone you ever had is 84 when you
guys wanted what are you watching
86 when you say just going back not
taking shots but still talking truth
you're always going to relive the glory
days well i mean if you if you're like
pat with his army stories they're always
going to have a glory days
where legendary glory hall of fame type
of stuff you kind of got to talk kind of
got to talk you got to talk about it's
not it's not like that that's a
different story anyways
i got a toy sitting right behind adam
yeah that's gonna be revealed
at around when we got three thousand
plus people live got to be revealed
and uh so if you're on here having fun
with us click on that thumbs up button
to get the seos on our different channel
and subscribe to the channel it is a
different channel we got a lot to talk
about
i say we get into the coinbase story how
about that we'll get to the coinbase
story
so coinbase uh it's on
fire okay coinbase ipo
here's what you need to know this is
story from forbes soon you'll be able to
buy the company
that helps you buy bitcoin coinbase the
largest cryptocurrency exchange in the
us has announced plans to go public
april 14th
with the ticker coin but it will uh it
will uh
uh pronounce that word for me uh adam it
will
take the traditional ipo process of
hiring investment banks to drum up
interest and finance deal
instead coinbase plans to post its
shares straight on the nasdaq stock
exchange via so-called
direct listing technique pioneered big
names like spotify and palantino recent
yours coinbase does not earn money
by charging you to store your
cryptocurrency in its popular wallet
service
instead it earns fees and commissions
when you actually buy and sell
cryptocurrency
a report from axios found that the
company was valued at 100 billion
dollars
when it sold shares on a private market
they're estimating it's going to be over
150 billion dollars which is more
than goldman sachs thoughts i
there has there ever been anything more
polarizing than bitcoin and the value of
it where you have
some experts that are so convinced that
this thing is going to tank it's going
to bottom out it's going to
continue to fluctuate and then you have
someone like robert kiyosaki yesterday
that's right who said it's going to go
to what 1.5
million unbelievable i mean you've got
smart people on both ends of this
i think this is great for coinbase yeah
because you're going to get so many
naive people that want to feel like
they're in the game that they're
they're involved in hey do you have any
bitcoin do you have any bitcoin well i
can't afford
one coin that cost sixty thousand
dollars but this can kind of say
at cocktail parties and with my peers
and in the locker room
when i'm getting dressed at the health
club yeah i've got bitcoin now or i'm
involved in cryptocurrency
i think there's gonna be a lot of people
lose a lot of money in this thing
because they don't know what they're
doing
i i'd say the vast majority of people
that get involved in something like this
don't know what they're doing but i
think it's a brilliant move by coinbase
what do you think yeah well there's a
couple different sides of the coin so to
speak so for the retail investors this
is essentially going to be sort of like
the robin hood
for crypto obviously robin hood there's
commission free trading and
you don't have to pay to make trades but
on this you do um
but yes i think a lot of people are
obviously super excited i think the ipo
is coming out
tomorrow i want to say but something
that people are not familiar with this
coinbase that is also known as sort of
the bankers
bank where a lot of the big banks out
there the goldman sachs of the world the
um credit suisse deutsche bank
everything they're using coinbase as
well
as sort of like um a custodian for all
their crypto this is where they're
holding all their crypto so
the one thing that that everyone has to
be concerned about when it comes to
crypto and bitcoin
is legitimacy is it secure is there
fraud i mean you know we've been
experiencing some stuff here at
valuetainment with all the nonsense
that's going on that's the biggest
challenge at this point
yeah so so look there's a couple things
i'll say that and i'll go into what you
just brought up right now look number
one is
the following the question like a lot of
people are asking is what is a better
investment
coinbase or bitcoin let me let me say
that one more time
are you better off investing in coinbase
are you better off investing in
in crypt bitcoin so if you buy a bitcoin
today at what
62 thousand dollars record-breaking high
pretty much it's at 62k right
you buy coinbase today it's a 150
billion dollar company
is it more likely that coinbase will go
to 300 billion
or cr bitcoin will go to 160 125 billion
125 000. is it more likely
that crypto uh that uh
coinbase will go to a 1.5
trillion dollar valuation or is it more
likely
that uh uh bitcoin's going to go to 620
000 valuation you know what i'm saying
so i mean a lot of people are like man i
totally missed on this whole coinbase
concept
but here's some news for people to be
thinking about if you missed it on
coinbase
there's another competitor out there
called binance
okay binance if you want to bring them
up binance b-i-n-a-n-c-e i think it came
out in 2017 if i'm not mistaken again
i may be wrong just type in binance uh
no take out the stock just type the
phone right here e
binance okay right there 2017 came out
it was 2018 bonus was the largest
cryptocurrency section
just so you know they have a token in
binance
called binance coin that's got the
market
cap right now of 85 billion dollars i
think click on it to see if it shows
uh finance coinvestor 89 billion dollars
as of right now you look at it right
there it's 89 billion dollars as of
right now
and they are competing directly
with coinbase yeah so this this is not
going away
this isn't just a coin based monopoly
there's other guys that are coming up
and they're going to be competing in the
marketplace
we also have gemini we also have gemini
yes we do we also have gemini and but
here's what i want you to be thinking
about he just
he just made a comment you kai go to go
to valuetainment and go to yesterday's
um go to youtube channel vitamin and go
to yesterday's interview
with dan price dan price type in dan
price
yeah let's go to dan price's interview
so check this out click on his interview
press pause so we're not listening to
the audio yeah so now go to
press pause press pause
okay go to comments go lower so
look at anybody that responds so say
this was great i really love this debate
click on the replies
see that's the problem this guy creates
a channel
not creates a channel he creates an
account
that's same exact logo same exact name
and look what it says
start investing in crypto btc and
ethereum trade to make
profits and puts a number there the way
they do so
uh google doesn't catch it because that
says whatsapp number
people are responding to it we got an
email this morning got mario called the
guy this guy sent an email this morning
saying hey
i gave you guys fifteen thousand dollars
of bitcoin you know
i need to get my money back to them
patrick owes me sixteen thousand dollars
right because
this guy named brian todd who works for
you guys
said that you guys if you i'm going to
get this mentorship and mario calls him
this morning david comes like this is
not us buddy
so the part with bitcoin where i believe
guys like him could potentially get the
government to step in
is those types of transactions that
happen
it's affecting people have spent nearly
a half a million dollars with
others who are saying this is not
because the same thing they're doing
here go to another comment by the way
look at this it's not a real channel go
to about how are they even able to
you can you can pull up how can they get
the name valuetainment but it's not
called valuetainment
it's just the logo so look when it
started february 25th so go back to the
other to our channel and go to another
comment that says something good
so go lower go a little lower go a
little lower go look the one that
doesn't have too many replies like
he tried to question patrick okay click
on that right there view okay again boom
again
by the way there are if i tell you one
thousand it's a small number
he has responded to 50 000 comments
this fake account we keep reporting it
to youtube
and youtube has not taken it down so if
i go on there
and i click on the channel to uh hide it
okay click on the channel right there
that is putting the comments
click on it right there to see to no no
the guy that commented
click on him the guy that the guy
valuetainment the fake account
okay so if we go out here to try to
block him
okay we report him and that's all you
can do
this is a separate one this just got
started april 9th so it's like
50 different fake accounts that they're
creating and people are falling for
scary so here's 12 000
of bitcoin i want to get you know into
the cryptocurrency patrick strategy i
would never have a cryptocurrency
strategy because for people to follow my
content they know we're not a crypto
but the challenge with crypto you get a
thousand of these that go to regulators
you get 10 000 of these you get 100 000
of these who typically ruins a great
opportunity
who scumbags scumbags con men right
who typically ruins a great opportunity
and brings over regulation yeah
people who abuse a great platform so
well any time that there's major money
obviously you're gonna have people
trying to do productivity you're gonna
have that's gonna happen i'm hoping this
does this is
why crypto is eventually going to get
regulated
i mean you can't have stuff like this
there's nothing i can do about it and
pat if this is happening in
valuetainment imagine how many other
channels this is happening to imagine
how many are the people
yeah they're going to people with
credibility and they're responding to
them and they're doing this on linkedin
left and right i have like 50 fake
accounts on linkedin they all block me
so i can't block them i don't know if
this makes sense or not so they start
the account
so it's a strategy they use they create
a linkedin account
they block the person they're copying so
you can't see it
they're responding to all the different
comments that people are posting
and then you're getting money out of
them saying hey if you'd like to be part
of a private
group hey send us a bitcoin here and
they're not taking it off credit cards
they're not taking it off any kind of
real
so any of that again that that part of
abuse could bring a lot of attention
from
regulators yeah who's at fault here
meaning
clearly the scumbags the fraudsters
they're guilty here they're at fault but
is there some naivete from people just
handing over their
crypto to somebody they meet online are
you not having are you not talking to
anybody on the phone
is there no vetting process are you just
trusting what you're seeing online but
you know what
what's the deal with that's your loyal
fan base if they see that logo they're
getting an issue yeah but
that might be legit i mean come on i i
mean look you have
three million followers on instagram
hundreds and hundreds of followers on
facebook
on valuetainment there's three we have
three million subscribers suppose we
have multiple channels
i mean little old me with you know
however many thousand followers i have
i get fake accounts and i get free and i
decided i have to tell people and it
happens all the time yeah
and i have 25 000 followers yeah so how
many people are
you have credibility though okay well so
do you so to you is my point
so my point is how do people not
understand
all right like well there's some product
this is this is the part where the
concept of getting verified
is very important the concept of seeing
who's sending your message
of a verified account is very important
but still
the naive part of getting ripped off
that's gonna happen man you gotta
listen there's not a single person you
cannot tell me you've never been ripped
off before you cannot tell me you know
everyone has everyone has and you're
going to fall for it at one point
that's a little bit without having a
conversation a little bit you guys are
forgetting one
element here of blame and that's the
social media companies i mean that they
can't have some sort of filter or you
send them
this fake account that's so obvious
because they're being bombarded billions
of times so for them to track
all of them youtube's sitting there
saying how can we track a billion yeah
one down and three pop up again that's
exactly they took one down and three
pop-up and we can't so
what's the game uh they used to play
whack-a-mole
isn't it amazing how quickly they can
take down the stuff they want to any
sort of negative talk or political talk
that they don't want up there that
disappears pretty quickly
yeah so anyways listen the whole point
is very happy
for the coinbase folks yes crypto
community
i have to tell you you can go change
your profile in the description for
those of you guys that were in crypto
pre bitcoin being a thousand dollars
some of you guys that weren't there
before was 500
you can put in your description today i
told you so you can literally put in
your description quote
i told you so me on crypto if you were
there pre 1000 you should in your
twitter profile
put something like that because you were
right and a lot of people sat there and
said
i don't know and by the way i was a part
of it i was one of them that sat there
and said i don't know what's going to
happen with crypto we don't know what
direction it's going to go to
my biggest concern from day one till
today with crypto has been what what's
been my biggest concern from day one
till today
regulation that's been my number one
biggest concern
and it's not changing just so you know
that especially under by the
administration we'll go deeper on that
what do you what when you say your
concern is regulation what are you
concerned about exactly well let me give
you a perfect idea let's go into the
china story okay let's go into okay with
china
uh not china's story with iran let's go
into the uh alibaba story okay
so this has to do with crypto in a way
that i'll tell the story which will make
sense so china hits alibaba with a
record-breaking 2.8 billion out dollar
fine
for behaving like a monopoly this is a
cnn business story
china has ordered alibaba to pay that
2.8 billion after antitrust regulators
concluded
that the online shopping giant had been
behaving like a monopoly china's
chinese state media reported saturday
that the state administration for market
regulation has imposed a
penalty following an anti-trust
investigation to alibaba's exclusive
dealing agreements that prevented
merchants from selling products on rival
e-commerce platforms
a practice known as choosing one from
two the fine is equivalent to
four percent of alibaba sale in china
sales in china and 2019 state news
agency reported
in an open letter published on saturday
alibaba said that the company has
cooperated with investigation and
accepted a penalty
with sincerity and will ensure our
compliance with
determination right now let me give you
some timeline security
1024 you know what happened on october
24th
ma gave that speech criticizing
regulators
november 3rd ma ant ipo was halted
in hong kong do you remember we talked
about in the podcast jack went missing
jack went missing right around two days
after 10 24
jack went missing okay on 11 10 november
10th
beijing drafts an anti-monopoly rules
for internet that's november
10th they write it that's three weeks
after his speech
december 24th beijing launches
anti-trust
probe into maz alibaba
organization and they summon ant
executives
that's on december 24th day before
christmas christmas eve
december 27th beijing demands ant
overhaul this is december 27th
okay now this is two months after ma's
speech
february 7th beijing releases a new
anti-monopoly rule for internet this is
new remember the first one they did that
on november 10th
well three months later they did a new
one that they released on anti-monopoly
on 4 10 april 10 two days ago they fined
them 2.8 billion dollars you know what
they're saying
uh hey entrepreneurs don't mess with us
you're not bigger than us we can do
whatever we want to do
to you u.s can do the same thing if they
want to to crypto
to write new rules and regulations janet
yellen is salivating
your girl she's salivating to get her
hands
on crypto today they're salivating now
is that why she keeps
dogging it of course yeah and you'll
hear a lot of them saying things like
the following
you'll see crypto communities say if you
really understand bitcoin
you would know they can never regulate
it okay which i get the argument there
but if you really understand the track
record of the us government and
government period
they have always figured out a way in
federal to regulate
whatever the hell they want to regulate
because you crypto community
are competition to them correct the best
news here
is the big dogs are also entering
the crypto space jp morgan chase goldman
sachs morgan stanley all these guys so
that's what i mean when you say what is
your biggest concern that's what i mean
by what china is doing u.s could
potentially do as well
but that's not all bad to have some sort
of regulation around crypto
to have some to prevent fraud first and
foremost
it it it depends on who you're saying
that to yeah
you have an audience that's going to say
we agree with you you have an audience
that's going to say what the hell are
you talking about adam here you go again
with more regulation and buying into
what janet yellen wants to do with the
new regulations
yeah okay just giving you both sides
paulo's also come out and said that
they're going to
potentially work on a digital dollar
from the u.s government not to compete
with the dollar but to complement the
you already you know when they say
they're printing money how do you think
they print the money it's digitally they
don't print the dollars like go print it
the dollar is printed digitally not a
hundred percent of money that they print
it's in printing press you just blew my
mind i didn't know that i thought they
literally printed them
no they print digitally even they
themselves have digital
right i mean i mean hard cash currency
is only a small part of the economy
exactly exactly digital printing is what
they're doing
well ma is clearly in the cross hairs of
this is only be
his nightmare is only beginning and you
know frankly
it's a copy in his country i i think he
should be very grateful the fact that he
built what he did
and was able to couple of the things
that you know g is the the president is
the one that literally
personally shut down the ipo he's the
one that made the decision
personally all by himself the other
thing that the chinese government is
doing here is they're trying to go after
alibaba's data right because they have
one billion customers
they have all this information on their
buying habits on their credit habits
and that's another thing that alibaba
and ant group has turned into is almost
like a bank
in china they're giving out low-interest
loans and that's the other thing that's
interfering with what china's trying
to do so you know not only has his
profile gone down
he still has not been seen in public
jack ma
has not made a public appearance he did
that tape thing in front of the school
maybe in january that was the first
sighting of it all but he hasn't been
out in public either so this is very
interesting he's worth 47
billion dollars right now alibaba is
huge it's
it's you know it's chinese amazon it's
incredible and it's not going anywhere
ever now that people are used to buying
everything online but this is something
really really interesting to follow and
whatever happens to him could he could
never leave
maybe he's out of the country do you
think he could just pack up and leave
and be gone
maybe maybe he's maybe he's done there
who knows oh
but what leaves with you the the problem
isn't leaving you know you know the guy
spoke to medic oven who bought people's
uh nft for 69 million
he said the reason why i've never moved
to california moved to state
is because of the fingerprints and all
the way of controlling you he says i
don't even want to go into the u.s
system because once
i'm there they're not even letting me
take my money with me so imagine if so
many people in america are worried that
if they leave your money's tied up you
can't take it out this is why they
criticize offshore
america that's america let alone free as
china
so you think the guy can take his money
from china yeah he may be worth 50
billion in china he's probably worth
half a million
in a different country unless he stashed
some of it over the years and could see
this coming because
how could this party not end for him
there is no way you could think that you
could continue to drive
say he moves to singapore do you think
they would still find a way to go get
him
you think he would you mean they would
item and physically talk about the ccp
of course take him go to uk you think
they would say you better give him to us
he has to go to a country
that hates china and is not allies with
china that wouldn't sit there and say
we're not going to do anything you know
so it's it's uh
jack ma is not bigger than china no one
in china is bigger than china
yeah so like you said there uh this is a
lesson for all entrepreneurs in china
you know look at this last quote that we
talked about on on this uh
on this segment an open letter published
on saturday alabama said the company has
cooperated with the investigation and
accepted the penalty
with sincerity and will ensure our
compliance and determination
right right you think they're happy
about this you think they're happy about
their 2.4
2.8 billion dollar fine no but they
learn their lesson and this is a lesson
for every other entrepreneur every other
country
other companies saying let's shut our
mouths i've got the perfect advice for
jack ma this is what he should have done
he should have moved to america and
married mackenzie bezos
he's a former school teacher she would
have loved him that's a good point
she would have been all over you know
what screenmatch.com how about
there it is center.com matches
billionaires together it's only got 400
members
it's only got 2200 members another
callback that we can talk about last
episode with ricky you talked about
the communist component of it the
government component of it but also the
capitalist component of it
it's a weird situation here where you're
free to be an entrepreneur and
and to an extent to an extent but then
the government steps in and
yeah so to an extent where you have to
you have to bow down and realize
you your voice cannot be more powerful
than the voice so
so there's one thing that's missing in
china it's called what freedom of speech
you don't have freedom of speech in
china
right let's just face it you just don't
have freedom of speech in china
okay what what what do people who win
want to do
what makes smart brilliant people what
they want to do say what they want to
say by the way think about it
go a little bit even deeper do you have
some opinions that you want to share
with the world
do you have some ideas about how you can
make china better
do you have some ideas what you can do
to make the government of china better
do you have some ideas if you're any
intellectual human being where you got
like
you know what if we did it this way like
imagine me saying hey we should have a
fifteen percent uh
right uh tax on tourists right and the
next thing you know valuetainment
podcast disappears
podcast disappears it's gone god hasn't
seen where is that that's exactly what
ma did
that's the point you can't do that in
china but don't you think jackman knew
that before he said something it
couldn't be that nice no
i felt i bet you think you didn't know i
think you get very comfortable in a
situation
like that remember that dog and pony
show that he came out to the u.s
and was yeah you know going to silicon
valley going to wall street being
treated like a god coming to hollywood
i believe you can believe some of that
in your mind and you think you're
untouchable
uh look the the thing over there with
jack ma the only thing i can
speculate again this is speculation the
only thing i can speculate is the phone
so
uh the rock right 220 something million
followers on instagram
he keeps coming out with a new product
every other day okay i love his products
that we mix with under armour when he
comes out with it i like it i support it
so he's retweeted some of my stuff hey
pbd thanks for you know
buying the products i like his gears i
quite frankly i never
liked under armour shoe it sucks no it's
horrible until the rock showed up i
didn't even know he had one i'm going to
check it out
we were just talking about how ugly
under the other shoes are
the flipping bombs i'm checking with
under armour no joke they're so
comfortable i love them hold it up
remember what the bad stuff was like
i like their outfits i i hated their
shoes by the way shout out to steph
curry just
became scored fifteen minutes not 50
something points but
last night he scored 53 points did he
score 53 points oh he had ten threes
that's right
he became the leading scorer in golden
yeah look at this they're not like this
right here that's the one i bought
they're so comfortable when you slip
them on right the rocks
they kind of look european though so
he's killing it but just
go to the red shoes of rock look at
these shoes he created so he kills it
with shoes then he goes and kills it
kills it with his uh tequila tequila
have you tried it i have not i have
is it good if you're used to drinking
casamigos which i am if i drink
uh tequila it's casamigos it tastes
nothing like that
it doesn't have that kind of agave why
don't we are you here thursday or
why don't we are you here next time on
the podcast okay thursday why don't we
order a bottle
and on the podcast let's i've never had
have you ever had it or not i have not
so you and i have never had it i've
never had it let's do a sample on the
podcast and see what it tastes like are
you saying that we're gonna do some day
drinking is that what you're saying no i
mean
a little bit by the way i will say this
about the rocks at home later it's a
it's economical
it's 32 bucks for a decent sized bottle
that would be 48.00
let's get a bottle of that as well it's
so funny we're not even doing a
sponsorship here
this episode is brought to you by the
rock by under armour
but here's where i'm going with this
yeah the only thing i said i started off
by saying i'm speculating so my
speculation was what
my speculation is jack ma is sitting
there saying what's next for me i'm the
richest man in china the world knows me
i'm the most influential man in china
when you think about china you don't
even know most people don't know china's
uh president or prime minister they know
jack ma more than they know him that
probably
more than she that probably rubs him the
wrong way not ma that probably rubs
the wrong way she says what if i make a
run at it so when you want to make a run
at politics what do you have to do you
have to start talking and giving some
political messages for people to kind of
say
i like this look what happened when the
uh the guy in china and russia did it
yeah putin comes out and says i can go
on re you know what he call it
another uh uh three terms three terms
two terms i'm also the sexiest man in
russia
russia so china's saying that's not how
we choose
prime ministers and presidents here
that's not how we choose it we choose in
a completely different way right
dwayne johnson in u.s makes all the
movies
paid actor back to back to back sexiest
man of life all these things that he
does right couple hundred million
followers
he sits there and says you know what
screw it seven bucks
i'm gonna go from seven bucks to the
president united states and he comes out
if you want to pull up the story what
page is that on by the way
it's late uh do we even have it in here
or no
we're okay 46 percent page five forty
six percent chance
46 percent of us one dwayne johnson as
president as he floats potential run
newsweek story at least 46
americans would support a presidential
run from dwayne the rock johnson
according to a new poll the actor and
former presidential wrestler has hinted
that
could be a 2024 candidate for several
years
a poll by pips people say suggest that
nearly half of all u.s adults would
support his candidacy the poll found
that 29
would support campaigns both by johnson
for president
and actor matthew mcconaughey for texas
governor the power conduct poll was
conducted
amongst 30 138 adults between april 2nd
and april 4th
johnson tweeted not sure our founding
fathers ever envisioned a six-four ball
tattooed
half black half samoan tequila drinking
pickup truck
driving fanny pack wearing guy joining
their club but if it ever happens it
would be my honor to serve the people
he's doing it there is absolutely no
doubt he
will run for president the only the only
question is what year
will it be he will run there's no
there's no doubt there's zero doubt
he just said it he says if the people
want me to duh
it's already happening all right i'll
tell you another thing the rock is bored
okay he's probably the busiest guy in
the world but he's bored as hell and
i'll tell you why
no offense but he doesn't make great
movies
i mean he makes good movies he makes
franchises jumanji bro he makes action
movies but it's the same thing he's not
winning academy awards
he's done what you can do making movies
he's
bored with it and i'll tell you another
thing he was
10 times more entertaining as a wrestler
i mean right now he's like a politician
where he wants to please everybody and
he's
you know he's he's very good at that
he's the best the best in the world
but there was nobody like the rock when
it came to wrestling there was not a
single more entertaining person
on this planet than dwayne johnson when
he was a wrestler
if i was always hoping there was a great
point there was never a doubt for me
that he was going to be a huge movie
star
my disappointment was he didn't carry
that rock persona
over into acting it always became i'm
going to try this acting i'm going to
take it serious i'm dwayne johnson
but he's going to run for president and
he'll probably win and i'll tell you why
because this works
politicians that come from hollywood
works because it's an outsider you have
the the name
clint eastwood mayor of carmel and he
was successful arnold schwarzenegger
governor of california
very very successful ronald reagan
president of the united states one of
the greatest ever i think he's going to
do it and i think he's going to win
and by the way just so you know neither
reagan
or arnold was as famous as the rock was
correct
that's what i'm saying close no no he
was a biased
president
maybe the biggest movie star at one time
arnold schwarzenegger barney
good old arnie that's your boy yeah yeah
i mean i can just i can see it now he
starts off
every press conference he shows up and
he goes can you smell
what the rock is cooking imagine if he
doesn't he sounded like an opera singer
yeah
i don't know i don't know i kind of
butchered that one but there it was
i could see him say can you smell but i
think
number let's talk about the things he
has going for number one number two
number three is name recognition are you
kidding me like
you can run for president you have the
best ideas ever you know let's just pick
on
andrew yang yeah you had great ideas
maybe you didn't like them maybe you
like them or not ubi what have you
bringing tech bringing math but nobody
knew who it was we had no chance yeah
tom delaney whoever this guy was exactly
you don't know who he is he has name
recognition
but i think the biggest thing that he
has going for him is there is a
huge hunger and appetite in this country
for a third party the third party lane
is completely
freaking one of you guys wide open i
mean i don't know if he's going to run
as a downer
like who knows yeah but the guy's got so
much money he'll have hollywood behind
him he'll have people
clearly donating the guy there's there's
just such a
the middle lane is wide open let's not
forget if he is going to run i think
that he would run as a democrat because
hollywood if you're listening to this
does he run as a democrat or a
republican or independent comment below
i'm curious
and then let's just not forget it was
maybe six months ago where goes where is
he
where is he and he starts getting crazy
like he's freaking on batman movie
talking about trump yeah
so he obviously is not a fan of trump
calling out trump but in my opinion did
you believe him
oh i believe he's an actor he's an actor
did you believe that he's totally giving
him
first it seemed fake i don't think he
likes trump i'm just put that
i don't think he likes trump but i also
don't think he likes biden yeah i think
he likes buying more than trump
i mean he remembers that he wouldn't
have to come out and do that
because he supported biden what do you
would do meaning he could have chosen
something well let me let me say this i
don't know if you ever watched the
interview
trump rock is very careful with his
words
go and watch the five minute clip of him
kamala and biden
he didn't go out there and fully endure
i don't know he says well
we hope that you're going to be able to
go out there and do the best things he
never fully supported it where's rock on
the political schedule center left
he's sent a right to me center right
he's exactly where i am is i think where
he's at
okay except i don't think he can be
allowed about it right he can't here
here's what to look at
if he runs as a democrat he's not
putting hollywood in his rearview mirror
if he runs as an independent it means
he's done with hollywood because you
can't go back
i don't think you could go back to
hollywood it will destroy him they will
destroy if he runs as what
if he runs as an independent he's done
in hollywood in my opinion if you run as
an independent and it's that freaking
bad to run
into people i think so i don't know i
think if you run as a republican yes
if you run as an independent no no not
as an independent i don't think you
could but
let me let me give you let me give you a
quick
question here and half statement here
running as an independent what are you
really saying
are you more center left or center right
right traditionally a little more center
right
exactly so but bernie sanders is
independent and
there's far from bernie sanders is
independently a socialist that's what he
is independent socialist
caucus is with the uh he caucuses with
socialists and communists that's what he
caucuses with period
democratic socialism right okay got it
let's raise taxes to 90
that's very democratic yes but let's go
back to the rock here let's go back to
the rock here
uh i i um i think he's got too many
people
in his ear that put way too much
pressure on him
i think he deep down inside is a
people pleaser and what i mean by this
is let me say this in the most
respectful way possible
i think he loves his mom and his family
obviously the guy is a
total family guy but his dad pushed him
a lot and he loves his mom
so he's got a soft place in his heart
for women a hundred percent
i think the guy is going to be very
protected there so if women come in
and tell him it's not fair it's not fair
it's not fair he may kind of be
tipping to that side so on any social
issues when it comes to women i think
he's going to support them
i think lgbtq i think he's going to
support them
uh military he's pro-military that's
what's so strange about it he's a
he's a pro-military fighter man so he's
going to support them not only a fighter
he's
he's pro-america he's got flags of
america everywhere
he's going to get heat for that and
criticism for that economically he's
made a lot of money that's going to be
on the right side
economically but if if
if if he becomes himself to run
if he becomes himself to run he'll make
change he'll make enemies
but if he becomes who everybody in
hollywood wants him to become to run
i think he'll be miserable i think he
will be miserable
one time uh he was doing an interview
with oprah winfrey
and somebody was asking him a question
about what happened between uh his
marriage when it fell apart you know
when
you know it didn't work out all this
other stuff and i don't know if you've
seen this interview
you can tell he really wants to say the
right thing
like he is so concerned about saying the
right thing okay
so much about saying the right thing i i
and by the way the the
the part with him that i think it could
fully be pulled off and he can be a
generational type of a leader because i
think what
trump could have done to unify
this guy could pull off now do i think
the rock can go
up against china and negotiate like i
think trump could negotiate with china
absolutely not
do i think rock could do that i don't
think so i think he's going to give she
the people his elbow
no i don't think so i don't think he
might suck him right in the shower i
don't think so because a lot of his
movies that he did in the last recent
years it was about china movies and he
was getting paid twice the amount of
money of what he would have done if it
was just the u.s
well once you start running for
president you you throw out your
your life i get that listen i'm telling
you for me i'm an optimistic guy i'm a
guy that's an optimistic guy and i'm a
guy that's a fan of his
uh his story is a fantastic story it'd
be a great story for kids to grow up
saying i want to be
like you know president you know
dwayne johnson when i grow up it's going
to be one of those things if you pull it
off
but i hope he comes out with some
policies to protect
taxes protect the military and still
figure out a way to tell both sides
you're a little too extreme you're a
little too extreme i'm going to be right
here
a couple of quick thoughts i do agree
with you that i think he is
uh uniter and i think he would be able
to unite the country
capitalists hollywood leftists liberals
uh flag you know all that i do i do
believe that
versus you know previous president who i
think was a divider
and that's more of a macro perspective
and then just something just a little
tidbit
that i'm going to throw in there is a
little ps don't forget where the rock
went to college
university of miami what is the biggest
swing state in the country
florida florida for the last few
elections has gone
to the to the right a little bit of red
a little bit of red but you know florida
is probably the most purple state in the
country
you know for the north tallahassee where
went to college a little more
uh conservative panhandle
the white trash riviera they call it up
there down south a little more
liberal obviously trump's here in
mar-a-lago so
i think he has the ability to make
florida the tipping point he's elected
if he wanted to do that he's way bigger
no clearly bro he's got to run in 50
states but florida
is a tipping point in any election if he
runs i don't think he'd need it i really
don't
here's what i would say about the rock
and to your point pat when he was a
wrestler he was so comfortable in his
skin because that was the family
business he knew it he knew it growing
up he knew it in and out
when he was in hollywood at the
beginning stages and even now he's
trying to conform to a certain degree
now he's just so damn talented and he's
so charismatic you know he's so good at
promoting and everything he's and he
does well in the types of movie he picks
that he's going to be super successful
my fear is that he would do the same
thing in politics that he's doing in
acting
is is trying not to offend trying to
just be a better
alternative than what we've had lately
go in there and kick some ass
and make some changes and don't care
what people say here's what he should do
career advice
101 for the rock run as a democrat
emulate john f kemmeny all right there
you go kennedy
john f kennedy you know you do that you
kind of follow that game plan
you know where you can play both sides a
little bit
you're gonna get that hollywood money
which you need you cannot turn your back
on hollywood you just can't do that if
you're the rock or wall street and i
think there's a way to do it you don't
have to be the same type of democrat i
think
republicans would embrace someone that
was a little bit not so crazy of what
we've seen on the left side lately yeah
i think if he goes that way
he is going to conform and he's not
going to be the president if he goes
that way
i think you're right if he wants to if
he wants to be
having that check mark of hey i'm
verified i'm 47
i'm 48 whatever if he wants to have that
check mark which only 47 48 people i've
ever had in the world which is being a
president of the greatest country in the
world fine then go take that route
but if you want to be the kind like a
lincoln if you want to be a kind like a
churchill
if you want to be a kind where history's
talk about you for hundreds of years
where you become a legend
forever and ever and ever to come yeah
you may want to run
with your core values deep down inside
and go back and remember what your mom
and dad taught you and what you were
raised by
that made you who you are today the
hard-working mother you know what that
he is
and that's what that's what a lot of
people around he's hardworking guy
no excuses that's already center right
okay that's a libertarian philosophy
you don't have to make excuses you can
make it work you have to improve
yourself this is
all center-right philosophies he doesn't
act like a victim he's not a victim he
doesn't make
excuses he never says poor me look what
happened to me i don't have any money
bail me out
this is a guy that's coming out saying
i'm going to figure out a way to go
straight to the top so can
you my fan that you're watching me here
and i'm going to kick your ass and
challenge you and inspire you to do the
same as well
i think if it's history sure you got to
do it a different way yeah if it's just
a check mark
go by the playbook that you just said i
agree he would be a president
i totally agree with you on the values
and principles there because i do think
he has a core set of values there i just
like the guy a lot let me like
i get people that say how can you say
this you know he's such a
dude stop i like the guy i mean people
don't understand i like you a lot
you know your your our relationship is
uh grown into what it is today
i like you a lot we may not agree
politically but i like you a lot i like
rock yeah i like rock as a guy as a dude
as who he is
uh i hope he uh makes the best of it
does it concern you at all yeah that
that
we haven't brought this up and no one's
really brought this up that's this
that we haven't talked about policies
perspectives
he's not excited yet though no meaning
the fact that you've never been the
mayor of a
little town or a governor of anything or
a senator never been
is that a good thing is that a bad thing
not knowing how washington works like
at least trump has donated to a million
different
one of the most political industries in
the world which is which is hollywood
are you kidding me this guy's been
playing politics
for 20 years dealing with the guy wwe
a very political organization the fact
that he made it around mcmahon and was
able to be the face yet not lose
credibility with mcmahon and mcmahon was
still the show this is all politics
the rock's been in politics for 30 years
no one just knows about it this guy may
be one of the best politicians we have
in america
politician i didn't say policies he may
be one of the best politicians
we have in america the last 30 years i'm
willing to bet some of rock's best
friends are republicans
and democrats and independent and gay
and straight and pro-military and not
military
i'm willing to bet this guy is one of
the best politicians
the last 30 years you know bottom line
is does he have your vote i don't know
yet i don't know
about you i have no idea but i will say
this my fear
today in april 13th is my fear is that
he's a doer he's a driver he likes
checking those boxes i think he would do
it to
show that he could do i don't think he
can do anything and not be great at it
so i think he wants to be
the biggest at everything and that means
president i don't know at this point if
i think he'd be a great president i
don't know that
but i will say this pat if you're
hosting the debate in four years you get
all your questions right from this
podcast question
you know today you got the rock here in
a presidential debate you can ask them
some of these questions
yeah i mean we listen the rock's got an
open invitational valuetainment he just
has to ask for but i know
i know his camp will say don't sit with
this guy
okay because he asks weird questions
don't go go sit with everybody that's
gonna ask basic questions but
uh i'm a fan i'm a supporter anything we
can to help spread his message whether
we agree or not we'd love to entertain
him okay
so having said that gang we're about 150
50 away from being
at 3 000. so i can show you this crazy
little toy that sold out within the
first hour that they announced within
the first hour it went live
it sold out in one hour it all sold out
and one of them is sitting back here and
it's
loud it's fast and it's the fastest in
the streets
zero to sixty it's insane when i ride it
it's
ridiculous how much power it's got but
we gotta get to three thousand we're
pretty close to it we'll get into it
here in a minute by the way
a lot of people said if the rock runs
we'd love to see steve austin run
stone cold that would be classic okay
so why don't we talk about a very soft
light topic so it's not too crazy why
don't we talk about the china
100 billion dollar deal with iran no
it's not lights off
nothing let's talk about it okay china
with a 400 billion dollar iran deal
could deepen influence in the middle
east new york times story
the countries have signed a sweeping
pact that calls for heavy chinese
investment in iran for 25 years in
exchange for oil step that could ease
iran's international isolation
china agreed to invest 400 billion
dollars in iran over 25 years in
exchange for steady's
supply of oil to fuel its growing
economy the deal
could deepen china's influence in the
middle east and undercut american
efforts to keep iran isolated
400 billion dollars of chinese
investment are to be made in dozens of
fields including banking
telecommunication port
railways healthcare and information
technology over the next 25 years in
exchange china would receive a regular
and heavily discounted supply of
iranian oil the deal also called for
deepening military cooperation including
joint training and exercises joint
research and
weapon development intelligence sharing
keyword
and intelligence sharing intelligence
sharing and iran has a lot of
intelligence
and this whole thing is going on while
iran still has
sanctions u.s still has sanctions
against iran that was imposed
by trump and they're still saying
america we're not worried about you
we're still going to do this 400 billion
dollar deal with china what do you think
about it
this is scary as hell this should be
this scares you
you don't think about going to iran for
vacation like i'm going to go to tehran
with adrian i'm good
i'm good i'm going to so iran i'm good
on going spending any money in china
this is
incredibly scary stuff any time that
china and iran are
talking about this kind of stuff you
know this is the lead story in the wall
street journal today the lead story
china's message to america we're an
equal now
this is the lead story in the wall
street journal so
the the the times can you pull that up
we're an equal now wall street journal
go ahead keep going
i send it to you on slack i believe kai
i don't know if that's uh i don't know
if you can get on the wall street
journal right there but
um keep going just go back and type that
into search we're an equal now go ahead
and i sent you it on slack if you need
to say that but look
you know it's something that definitely
i was aware of
um before i came to valuetainment a year
ago
and now that i'm acutely aware of is
china standing in the world they are
coming here it is right here
they are coming after america and they
they're coming for the top spot
and you know their whole message here to
america when they sat down and they had
this meeting is
essentially like look what the hell is
going on in your country you guys are
freaking divided
you're racially divided you're socially
divided you're politically divided
we're unified yeah nobody can say [ __ ]
because if they do they'll get jack mod
but um
[Music]
that guy right there pull him up he
basically took i think 16 minutes
scroll down kyle you'll see it he
basically landed yeah let me let me read
that channel
no no kai just go to exactly china can
already look at the world on equal level
he told the annual legislature
sessions in beijing in early march a
remark widely interpreted in chinese
media as a declaration that china no
longer looks up to the us
the u.s routinely described china as a
strategic rival but beijing has rarely
if ever used such terms emphasizing
terms like win-win and cooperation one
of the more obvious
changes in chinese attitude is that
china now recognize the existence of
competition which was never
expressed in the past says uh wang and
advisor of china state council and
president senator very interesting
very interesting and then they say um
kai can you just i think it's
maybe one sentence up or one sentence
down it was very intriguing
this part right here um competitive
leadership mr yang's warning in alaska
and taiwan's reunification is announced
ominous uh uh in clink of how
competitive relations between the world
powers and uh
could lead to conflict the us is
committed to helping taiwan preserve
their
its autonomy under pledges including the
1979 taiwan relations act and the biden
team trumpets
its plan to strengthen economic and
political links to type uh
taipei mr xi has made a reunification
with taiwan
which beijing regards as a breakaway
province a big part of his china dream
of national rival
chinese foreign ministry says mr yang's
anchorage warning the chinese side
pointed out that the taiwan issues
related to chinese china's
sovereignty and territorial integrity in
china's core interest it has there is no
room for compromise
kai go to the just top sentence i
believe that it may have been the first
sentence
they said something to the effect of um
the kind of
dialogue
basically the whatever beijing wanted to
restore the kind of occurring dialogue
washington sees as a waste of time says
u.s and chinese officials
briefed on alaska meeting what point are
you trying to make yeah adam
is challenging over a bit basically
essentially just sort of gave an
overview of their perspectives
for years they just said stay quiet keep
it up guy
they said stay quiet don't you know rock
the boat a little bit
you know sort of their 20 30 plan that
they've been planning and now that's
getting exacerbated because of the
pandemic and everything that's happened
and printing our money
and look message to americans message to
my fellow americans here
that's enemy number one okay that not
your
not if you're a democrat it's not the
republican if you're republican it's not
the democrat
you know i had a conversation with our
friend ricky the other day
and i assume a lot of people feel this
way uh i asked him who
who do you like more who do you like
more
joe biden or vladimir putin and he goes
oh putin not even not even freaking
close i go hold on you're telling me
that you like
putin better than biden
an american what does it like mean
defining meeting like who you respect
more who you like more respect like who
has more power
who's smarter he's wiser who's better
strategic
fill in the blank american president
russian president who do you want who do
you
sympathize that's a different question
that's my question yeah
but my point is a lot of people and and
there's interviews like this all over
where people would would say i i'm i'm
more into putin i don't know the correct
word here but i am more
sympathized i don't think people say
that i i have to be careful
i don't i think you got to choose your
words carefully when you say this
because this is a very important topic
i think people think putin is stronger
and a better leader than biden but
people don't sit there and say i hope
putin succeeds
you think american people say putin i
think there's
a segment of the republican wing that
does you are out of your mind and i
also think there's a segment you cannot
just have said this listen i'm also
going to say this i think there's a
segment of the democratic
party that looks at trump as a worse
person than putin or even she
and that's ultimately my point as as
fellow americans are not your enemies
i do know about that no i don't i don't
no no i i don't think that people
actually think
you cannot you mean to tell me american
people republican or democrat or
independent are rooting for putin
let me use this one let me use this word
correctly i think that many americans
democrats specifically hate trump more
than they hate putin or she
and i think conversely i think a lot of
republicans
hate biden or hillary clinton more than
they do different
that's different than wanting putin to
succeed
that's different than wanting xi to
succeed i would hope so but no no no no
that's different than wanting
listen but say that
say what you just said okay let's say
that exists yes tell me what percentage
of america
is actually the person you just
described what percentage of americans
actually if it's one percentage that's
what i need no no that's
one percent say ten percent on both
sides no
it's probably one percent it's probably
one percent that says that but that one
percent is so loud that they make you
think it's 20
that's the problem with these guys
sometimes the complainers are so loud it
convinces the world
that they have so many people following
them they don't
it's a one person no it's not hope so
it's not well ultimately my point is
this how many people
i mean how many people in the street how
many people out there in the streets
okay
a hundred people you run into how many
of them are willing to rob your car
right now and take your money from
you out of 100 people one oh that's so
what are you gonna you're gonna judge
the other 99 the one come on man
i don't think we can do that if but but
to say they're they're fine by the way
do you see the conflict that's going on
right now with russia and ukraine are
you kind of following that yeah over
crimea and all that yeah
so and you know us is you know with the
hopes of hey
if we support ukraine what could happen
with russia and russia gets involved
right
by the way just everybody knows russia
right now so does u.s but russia right
now
has nuclear bombs targeted to every
major city in america that can get here
within 30 minutes
just so you know that 30 minutes it's
here we also have the same
same we have nato everything over there
yeah so do we
so do they but they got it within 30
minutes it's it's a very
uh that's not is that new i mean that's
been going on it's not about it
but ukraine and russia look look at
china and taiwan
how sensitive is that to china extremely
sensitive like number one how sensitive
is
ukraine russia to russia extremely
scientific how sensitive is
iran us with what china just did yes
extremely sensitive you know what is
happening people are
disregarding the level of sensitivity
today so china's saying oh okay us
you're supporting this no problem i'm
going to support iran
by the way iran the people of iran have
no idea what this means
there's a couple things you have to
think about with iran okay i haven't
even come to i'm sorry go ahead if you
want
a couple things about iran so you have
to know one part of iran is sitting here
saying what
okay so now we have china that's backing
us up and giving us 400 billion
over how many years 25 years so china's
own china essentially owns
iran for 25 years and africa by the way
just a little ps
out through africa in africa in africa
okay kai i sent you a
two links that if you can pull up one of
them was a couple things i just want you
to look at okay
one of them was the uh yeah go up a
little bit this is u.s allies go a
little lower
okay and then go to natural resources
which is a link prior that i sent you 10
countries with the most natural
resources okay
close it up close it up close up go back
go back to another link i don't want
them to see it i don't want them to see
it
can you tell me what country number one
has the most natural resources did you
see it or not
did you see it or no did you see what
country in the world has the most
natural resources
if you're watching this right now what
country in the world do you think has
the most natural resources
what country i want you to actually
comment what country in the world
do you think has the most natural
resource it's around 24 trillion dollars
23.6 trillion dollars and it's not the
united states
i want you to guess it it's okay if you
want to guess it what country do you say
kai did you see it or no you know it sam
did you see it
what country think in the world just
throw that i'm guessing it's either the
usa or freaking china
okay us or china what are you going to
say natural resources
so you got a lot of countries in the
middle east that you think about right
they're
not on my list okay so let's check this
out a lot of people are saying russia
venezuela it's on the list china sweden
russia
congo iran venezuela all these other
things okay i'm going with china here go
to
go to the list now go to the list now go
up
go up go up like keep going down is what
i mean
okay 10 is australia okay nine is
congo good call by the way somebody said
congo eight is venezuela
14.3 trillion dollars worth of natural
resources united states is
seventh okay keep going lower keep going
lower
brazil sixth 21.8 trillion dollars
including gold iron oil and aluminum
uranium keep going lower five is russia
75 trillion dollars but they're five
four is india which they're going to
compete and
india is a u.s ally which is good news
okay keep going
three is canada it's a little concerning
with canada okay because
canada's got a better relationship now
with china than they do with u.s you'll
see here in a minute i'll show it to you
go to number two saudi arabia obviously
and number one
the most natural resources china china
tops the list for having the most
natural resources
estimated to be worth 23 trillion
dollars 90 percent of china's resource
are coal
and rare earth metals however timber is
another major united st
the list goes on right okay so now go to
the other link that i sent you to see
what
allies this is many cus as their top
ally i wanted to find out what countries
see us as their top ally wow
israel's 82 but look at china because
this is a very important thing to look
at comparing
do me a favor flip the screen make this
the bigger screen us the smaller screen
sam if you can do that
flip us so they're seeing this more than
they're seeing us israel 82
u.s one percent china
82 israel is a like better uh
ally with the u.s than there is u.s
versus china u.s china and
other countries so whatever their other
country it would be notable
south korea were number one look at
where china is four percent this is good
okay philippines by the way look at
china whoever
who else is four percent north korea is
that and the other country name does
that
is that ally or most name country that
people would make that
in this argument philippines 64 china's
nine percent not even close
japan 63. look at china one this is good
for us canada 46. i'm sorry canada which
one's the one that i said canada with
china okay canada was a normal china it
was another one
no it was another one i was making a
comparison to which we'll get with uh
you'll see where i'm going to go here
with one of them okay so canada 46
2 uk 14 australia 38
china six australia's neighbors with
china still six
kenya china 30.
brazil 32 to the u.s eight to china
nigeria 27-22 which you mentioned
earlier mexico look at mexico
interesting
27 and 16 south africa 24 and 19
india 21-3 meaning 21 is u.s
indonesia 16-6 argentina 15-5 lebanon
tunisia look at turkey that's my concern
that is my concern
it's turkey and you'll see where i'm
going with this go a little lower go a
little lower
go lower lower lower lower go lower go
lower i think there was one of the chart
here
and then across different countries both
the u.s and china emerge as key threats
okay mexico mexico you got it uh
percentage hussey
uh such and such country or group that
poses greatest threat to their country
okay uh mexico u.s turkey
u.s argentina u.s canada you see how
that works out okay canada that's the
one i was talking about
where china is ahead with canada as a
threat you see where that
but it's equal number here's the point
when you see this here
and you see what iran's doing with china
is doing with iran
right there's a couple things
there's a couple things that we are not
paying very close attention to here's
one of them
you have to know that if you can flip
the screen now i don't know if oh you
weren't able to do it
look at the last one by the way us
three percent of the us think we are our
own biggest uh
enemy but he here's the party you have
to think about if you can rush it you
can close it up kind just bring it to me
so we can get everyone's attention
so here's the part the challenge we had
three thousand by the way
the challenge we have now in the us is
the following in in in
china is the following what people don't
realize is
those extremists in iran who are the
loudest people in the world
the 99 percent or the one person
how many extremists does iran have low
numbers it's it's
they have a good number but meaning they
have them they have extremists okay
and they're sitting there saying wait a
minute so imagine like the aoc of iran
who's a super extremist religious
leader all the way
i'm not going to say left or right all
i'm extreme religious that they're going
to sit there and say
wait a minute uh iran why are we doing a
deal with china
isn't china persecuting uyghurs
muslims have you seen what china is
doing to muslims wait a minute
are you trying to tell me money is now
more important than
our profit and are are you telling me
that that's more important
oh okay okay see what we're going to do
to you now
so what china doesn't realize they're
about to experience
is the following see folks i lived in
iran
when i lived in iran for 10 years you
know who was iran's number one enemy
u.s you know why because the extremists
in iran would say hey
shah why are you lining up with u.s
look what they're doing to our daughters
they're making our daughters not wear
clothes and not where you know what do
you call it
they're no longer conservative they're
not wearing the hijab you are making us
westernized and we
hate you for it what happened they
eventually kicked them out
okay the extremists in iran right now
are saying why are we lining up with
somebody that doesn't like our religion
why are we lining up with somebody that
sits there and tells the muslims of
china to go out there in front of camera
so they can track them and see exactly
where they're going
why why are we not why are you why are
you teaming up with them
so we are not going to see the side
effects of this
for at least five to ten years okay i
don't think you're gonna see the side
effects of this
for six months twelve months everybody's
celebrating right now oh we got this
on the other hand on the other hand why
is this deal taking place four months
after trump's not in office anymore
why why are they doing this deal three
months after trump's and what is the
january 21st whatever the date is what's
the last day trump was in office
is it the 20th okay why are they doing
it now
because they don't care they're not
afraid of u.s they're not sitting there
saying oh
the sanctions you have on iran let us
not do because biden's going to come
after us they're saying dude
we're going to do the deal and there's
nothing u.s or biden's
going to do about it yeah here we go and
they're first they may be wrong
this deal has been in the works for a
while now it's not like it just came up
yeah but it just got done right
okay okay i agree with you guys 400
billion is getting done now so now
you're seeing the deal getting done
how much was u.s going to pay iran to
part of the nuclear deal 150. it was 150
million
150 billion so this is 3x that give or
take here i'll throw a couple things out
at you you know when when i look at
these numbers from the story
you know everybody looks at 400 billion
dollars and think that's unbelievable
but if you amortize that over 25 years
it's not that much
25 years though that they have them
under their thumb is unbelievable and
that's what china does
and when i when i saw that data that you
put up over there and i saw
mexico list china as a 26 percent their
number one alley
ally i had no idea they even thought of
china as even a remote
allies exactly and that is what china
does
that's their diplomacy they throw all
kinds of money into countries they build
up their infrastructure and then they
own them
i mean could you imagine if china had a
huge presence in mexico
that is a very very big problem for the
united states and here's my question
when you see all this and
you hear iran you hear china you're you
know all these threats and all the scary
talk about it but
what do you guys think is the end game
for a china
for an iran it's economic dominance
isn't it not so much iran but for china
they want to be the number one economy
this isn't a warfare
type thing where they want to come in
and take over this country i don't think
isn't it where they're just trying to
become the most dominant
country on the planet no questions so
think about it this way who has an
advantage the person that's dominating
right now or the most ambitious
person behind closed doors that's
monitoring how you dominated for the
last 50 years for me to study all the
right wrong in the mistakes
exactly what china's doing who is got
the edge
china does and china is exploiting
that edge that they've had watching
exactly what us has done and look at
them now
okay and and by the way this isn't just
about
made in china 2025 we're going to be the
largest you know most powerful regime in
the world
this is influence control and it's
long-term it is not short-term and if
they do take over
they're going to be imposing think about
it this way you know how they said if
germany would have won everybody in the
world would have been speaking what
language
german right oh hitler would have wanted
germa everybody would have been speaking
german right
okay well we know what happened we all
speak what
british english whatever you want to
call it we speak english right okay
but what else has u.s imposed to people
around the world hey
mr gorbachev please tear down that wall
you know hey
what you guys need communism yugoslavia
you need capitalism hey
china what you guys need to do is you
need to let your people own business and
be capitalists hey
uh gorbachev the problem that you have
in your countries everybody drives the
same car everybody drives the same
clothes let your people compete so these
people say well that's a great idea
we're gonna we're gonna take capital
zaman
but yes what china's gonna do now
they're gonna go and post
their philosophies and what's one of
their philosophies silencing you
silencing you their philosophies is no
philosophies
their philosophy is therefore our way or
the highway
and the number one power china has
is silencing people even if you're the
most richest man in
china china even if you're the richest
man in america because look at elon musk
they said don't
uh video have video cameras on yeah they
don't have the kind of control over
myself but in china they do we've
cracked three thousand but go ahead in
china china they do yeah
yeah they impose not having uh letting
tesla videotape anything on their cars
right anyway we cracked three thousand
it's a big if you wanna come up so folks
here's what i'm gonna do we crack 3000
i'm going to show you this toy here that
just arrived last week i've been writing
it i've been having a blast with it
and i'm going to give you another
surprise this sunday nobody knows that's
the crazy surprise that's going to come
this sunday you know what the crazy
surprise i think you out of everybody
knows what the crazy surprise is
but which camera are you going to use
are you going to use that camera i'm
going to turn it on
so you may want to lower your audio if
you're riding in the car and listening
to this or if you're at work
lower the audio because i want you to
listen to the engine maybe put your ear
muffs on because when i do it you lord a
little bit yourself did you bring it
down earmuffs
yeah you're going to hear how loud this
thing is but i want to show you the
details of this ridiculous thing that we
have here
and then we got a few more topics to get
to before we wrap up the next 35 minutes
so hang tight
okay need a drum roll you got the camera
yeah
are you gonna move with that camera
hold on let me get some social media
presents going on here dvd
okay once you're ready which way are you
is it on or no
yes okay all right let me pull it up a
little bit here we go
all right here we go check this out okay
sam if you want to bring the camera
closer
this is the new if you want to come
closer here
this is the first ever collaboration
between lamborghini and ducati okay
first ever collaboration between the two
the lamborghini that came out the same
exact kit that they use they used on
this by the way if you touch it
it's so sleek it's ridiculous it's the
fastest bike
in the streets right now zero to sixty
this 63
represents the euro lamborghini got
started what most people don't know is
the fact that lamborghini was bought
by audi and audi also bought ducati
so it's a collaboration between the two
they only made they only brought
60 in the u.s 600 made period worldwide
60 of them is in us if you want to come
around so they can see this angle
like this literally just came in if you
can see this
the tires are brand spanking no i
haven't even put them in you see those
fat tires look at the wheels
the color of the wheels can you pull it
out a little bit or no yes okay good
look at the wheels what it looks like
it's the same exact color wheels as the
lambo
if you want to pull it a little bit it's
the
what color is that by the way uh there's
uh there's a there's something cold they
call it what do they call it
uh there's a name for it on the gold
but it's beautiful when you see this i
mean it pops when you're writing it out
there
everything is numbered at a 6 30 they
made 6 30 of them this is 4 17
out of 6 30. there's only there's only
60 of these in the u.s this being one of
them
and when i ride it it's absolutely
ridiculous 1260 lambo it's part of the
diavel
family just a gorgeous bike so
yeah i mean i i got this and i said i'm
going to bring it on the podcast maybe
have it be on the set
for the next few weeks but the new
ducati lamborghini diablo 1260
is isn't the house with only 16 u.s you
know what's crazy is the fact that 60 of
them sold out
in the first hour in the u.s i believe
that that's crazy
yeah they announced it within the first
hour they're like it's done i called
everywhere
everywhere to see if we can get one
called every single place i could
eventually my uh good people here
is it the gym uh adam is a gym and mario
at the miami ducati dealership or is it
for the pompano ducati dealership
uh and i called newport i called fort
worth i called
virginia's ducati i called uh
dallas i called la i called everyone
finally got one that came in last week
anyway congrats
yes that's the ducati lamborghini
collaboration
lamborghini gorgeous man it's just
beautiful
if you see it in the streets take a
picture of them because you're only
going to see 60 of these
and that's like a bowl on the front too
isn't it or what is that now you want to
hear what it sounds like yeah
okay let's let's turn it off okay here
we go get your earmuffs ready
ear muffins ladies and gentlemen ear
muffins watch me fly into
yeah thanks
might be the new owner of valuetainment
so have you been on the streets with it
of course do you get uh
i would imagine you get some great
reaction oh but i don't even you can't
even tell
yeah flies when you're going on it but
uh is that street legal is that street
legal right there that is street legal
the other one i've actually never i've
always wanted to use that term street
legal
yeah i don't i think the ubers you drive
they're all streaming you know i think
the most interesting
how many did you say 60 60. it'd be
great to see the roster of the people
that actually got him i think the people
that are on that roster probably
are all die hard raise the volume a
little bit because we're low let's go
back to normal
i think they're probably part of the die
hard ducati community it's a crazy
community
you're talking about the ferrari the
lambo of motorcycles when you think
about ducati that's what it is
what aston martin did they teamed up
with an old
bike company that used to be called the
rolls royce of bikes
and they got a bike that came out and
that one is not street legal so that's
more for somebody like you who loves
speed i know you love
speed just adam's speed guy
even now in your 40s on a motorcycle
come on adam
let me put it through this way there's
nothing in adam's body
that likes speed okay nothing adam if
the speed limit's at 65 he won 60
is what he prefers i once got pulled
over for going too slow did you really
do i actually believe it yeah i did
seriously yeah i got i mean you know how
you know why i believe this so we go to
the andretti racetrack
to go race you know what he does he's on
the right
letting everybody pass and he's waving
out all of us and he's just cruising
okay cruising and paul paul e was
fantastic
it's funny though some people are built
for speed and others aren't i mean that
does not throw i'm more in adam's
category i'm not into it
you know i've been to bob bondurant's
race thing many many times and
i'm not really into it some people are
built for speed some people are built
for comfort just you know
listen whatever whatever floats your
boat man when i when i when i played
sports though
when i ran the 40 when i played football
it was the fastest you ran the 40
459. would you run it in probably about
a four
four nine or four five oh really
yeah center yes wait a minute you said
you were all what you were all uh uh
i mean i look i was a football player i
was an athlete and i was pretty fast yes
so
four or five for sure legit
by the way we just uh we just confirmed
uh we're renting out the whole dallas
cowboys stadium
and as a surprise to everybody i
announced last week bo jackson's gonna
come join us
we brought both jackson yeah who was a
better [ __ ]
bo jackson or deion sanders who's a
better athlete yes all around all around
i
don't know that's a tough one that's
what i put it that's why i put it up i
would
probably say the edge i don't know
they say balls one is thunder one is
lightning
they said bo ran a four one nine god
that's ridiculous who's faster bo
jackson
they say on standards
yeah dion said both faster wow that's
scary
it might be it'd be close you know here
maybe now maybe now i could take dion
but i think we set that up you know if
bo hadn't been hurt he may have been the
most accomplished athlete of all those
for sure as a question yesterday on
twitter saying who's the greatest
running back of all time you'd be
surprised
what people said but who do you think's
the greatest running back of all time uh
i'll go with
walter payton who do you see barry
sanders
yeah i would say barry sanders as well
but there was arguments for jim brown
yeah okay he 12 seasons a thousand yards
whatever the number they put i don't
know the exact number but that's
somebody who commented i don't even
think it could be 12 cent maybe it is 12
citizens with the
thousand yards some put ap adrian
peterson oh no they put as a top five
yeah emmits made top five statistically
they said that barry sanders had emma
line he would have destroyed everybody
yes maybe this eric dickerson was he
eric dickerson was on that list yes
what about o.j what about oj people said
oj was hilarious and some people said lt
ladainian thomas yeah he had a couple
good seasons hey respect to marshall
foster i
i don't i think you've got to run that
in a top 10 top 15. you know
oj screwed himself though because he was
phenomenal he was an unbelievable
running back but nobody thinks about it
hate when you screw yourself by killing
two people okay so let me ask this who's
a better athlete deion sanders or bo
jackson thumbs up bo jackson thumbs down
deion sanders right here
we got 680 let me see the exact thing
that we got right now we got 707 thumbs
up seven thumbs down
bo jackson thumbs up dion sanders thumbs
down watch us get about 200 thumbs down
now in a minute because people say dion
i'm actually curious right now
to our anti-sports community this is
they're going crazy right now saying
stop talking sports
but uh okay all right so let's see what
we want to talk about next do you have
any specific topic you want to go how
about the apple
uh the new apple tv with the microphone
i'm going to veto you i'm going to veto
you you're like
one boring story like we either need to
go to
americans investing or our friend mark
zuckerberg on facebook
i'll go with zuck then okay what page is
he on zuck is on page four okay let's go
to page four here we go the story
is a story by fox business
facebook spent 23 million dollars on
mark zuckerberg security in 2020
uh 23 million dollars on security for
ceo and found myself in 2020 fiscal year
social media giant disclosed last week
facebook spent more than 13.4 million
on personal security for zuck at his
residency as it residences
and during personal travel zuck also
received 10 million
pre-tax allowance to cover additional
security equipment and personnel for
his family the security costs rose
slightly compared to 2019
when facebook spent only 10.4 million as
well as 10 million allowance facebook
said zuckerberg is a unique position
because
negative sentiment regarding our company
is directly associated with them
23 million what do you think about it i
don't think it sounds exorbitant
at all take a look at mark zuckerberg
the guy looks frazzled
all the time all the time i mean i have
never seen a picture of him or a video
of him where he looks calm cool
you know relaxed the number of threats
he must be facing are astronomical if
you think about
every celebrity is harassed on some
level the biggest ones are stalked and
their life's in danger
we just don't know sometimes you hear
about it but it's real
and i can only imagine with the
controversial stances that facebook
takes and he
is facebook he is the face of it he is
he is the whole thing as much as
one person can be identified with a
brand as can possibly be
so i i don't think 23 million to protect
an investment
of trillion of a trillion dollars is
that exorbitant at all
and i'll say this what did seem high to
me when i looked at this story a little
bit more in depth is they spent six
million dollars in security
on cheryl sandberg to me that seems like
a hell of a lot of money to be spending
on
a lower level executive if you look at
the numbers for other
ceos of tech companies jack dorsey i
mean i think he's on
what i think it's around 3 million they
spend on him eric schmidt was 300k
when he was at google uh the ceo of
google or when yeah the ceo of google
now
1.2 million so and and tim cook is
pretty low he's about 800 000 for his
annual
security is what apple said so you know
there's just a lot of threats on him i
would imagine he travels a lot he you
know he has compounds in hawaii so
there's a lot of travel i i think a part
of it has to be linked to
hate it like you know hate it in most
potential future influence i combine
those two together so
tim cook does he hate it no no not
really does he have future influence of
wanting to go out and run for office
i don't know if tim cook's gonna run for
office right okay you
talk about uh cheryl sandberg is she
hated yeah she's part of facebook
is she important without cheryl sandberg
they're not doing the kind of revenue
that they're doing so she's
very powerful on what she changed again
when she came from google and she
brought the algorithms
to facebook i had kenneth bombass on
okay i don't know if you remember two
months ago two and a half months ago
this guy's a uh bodyguard executive
protection
is what they do and the company is
called global threat solutions right and
he and i were speaking i said let me ask
you a question
he's represented clinton presidents
billionaires a bunch of different people
that he's represented okay
i asked him you know what is the life i
don't know if you guys remember when we
talk about the fact that the
bodyguards actually don't know how to
fight they know how to run great
bodyguards and
uh executive protection guys are great
runners they don't fight you they hit
and run that's what they do they don't
sit there and say you want to fight
they're not looking for eight degree
black belt they're looking for a guy
that can know how to leave the building
the fastest
that's their specialty pretty
interesting when you think about them
and take their
subject with them so you want a skinny
small executive protection guy that
knows how to fight defend
and leave is what they want to do we all
saw the bodyguard with kevin costner
there you go okay so
pretty much visualize that versus the
six eight three hundred
that's not a that's not executive that's
like the rapper's bodyguard that's a
show that's that's that's the show
like hopefully so i asked them so let me
ask you a question if i wanna get
bodyguard you know i wanna get your
service how much is it gonna cost me so
what are you looking for
i said what if i want to have a couple
people full-time at my house all the
time one in the front one in the back
he says well you have to realize that's
three a day so what do you mean it's
three a day
sure he says it shifts it's eight hours
it's not only three a day
they can only work five days so you
really have three a day
so that's three times three is what
that's three times two is six
he says you know then six you gotta add
three more because the days they're off
they're working so you add
nine is what you got let's just say you
get so you do the math so the additional
two days is additional so that's 12
is what you're dealing with okay and he
said
camera everything to be there full
protection travel all that he says
you're looking at about three and a half
million dollars a year whoa
yeah so that's about three and a half i
said what'd you say it says three and a
half million dollars a year
i said three and a half he says yep it
says you got to calculate
around a thousand a dollar a day for a
real good one
so without a day times three times
you're he's doing a whole calculation
you're looking at two and a half to
three and a half million a year yeah so
regular billionaires are getting two
million dollars to three and a half
million dollars for body card service
for something like this
32 million for zuck 23 million dollars
for zuck i think it's a deal i think
it's a steal
that's also if you only have one
bodyguard we can't hear you raise this
volume please i can barely hear them
go ahead uh that's only if you have one
bodyguard at a time yep like
three that's right yeah so now imagine
you have two or three
and like one of them is a driver
automatically now you're traveling
just jets car restaurants constantly and
then also a big thing that was in the
story is that
last year what happened last year pretty
controversial year in many ways it's
election year
imagine the money they get spent on
facebook to sway ads either way
and him i mean he was probably one of
the biggest one in the hot seat for
things that they allowed things that
they fact checked this that and the
other
so i mean it makes sense that it goes up
by the way they voted bo jackson has a
better athlete
yeah so i thought so well anyway this
this uh we got some stats for you
um yeah on mark zuckerberg this comes
out to two million dollars a month about
65 grand a day
uh but you talked about being a
controversial figure and how much is
health cost and approval man
you know obviously he's worth over a
hundred billion dollars at this point
let's just talk about favorable and
unfavorable ratings facebook's favorable
rating
43 unfavorable rating 47
okay so more i'm surprised it's not
higher unfavorable right yeah i'm
surprised
let me keep going mark zuckerberg's
favorable rating 20
unfavorable 56 percent to put it in
perspective
trump's favorable rating was 40 50
56 unfavorable keep going zuk
does he have too much power power 73
say yes 41 say that that zuck
should resign the only ceo in the
country only tech ceo in the country
that has an actual
positive net approval rating is your
friend tim cook 23
favorable 18 unfavorable just a couple
more
stats for you does facebook have too
much power 69
said yes and then um
[Music]
last at does 57 believe facebook is
primarily a harm to society and 71
believe the company prioritizes profits
even if it causes societal harm
you know if you if not good ratings for
your friends of three million dollars
for yourself
these other guys are lying jack dorsey's
they're their numbers they're lying what
did jack dorsey
they said it was like uh
79 000 out of your mind i know i know
and literally that's what they said for
eric schmidt 300k and 1.2
the only reason why i would believe a 79
000 is if you live in the office and you
never leave
and you have to count the company's
security as personal security right
you have to have security exactly the
amount of money they invested in twitter
security in the building you know how
much money they probably put into
security cameras
key cards all of that you know how much
that costs that's a massive ticket right
there
so no i don't think he's spending
seventy nine thousand dollars and twenty
we just learned that people really
really don't like zuck
and they really don't like facebook but
so zuck the human robot
well why though think about why here's
what i want you to think about we just
talked about the rock running because
he's got 220 million instagram followers
zuck running he's got two and a half
billion followers yeah
if zach zuck is the the only guy if you
think about that if he runs
he can be the new world order leader if
you actually think about it because he's
got
world global influence don't give him
any ideas
interesting you did the art the
interview with medicovin he said that
these tech companies
virtual government virtual governments
yep that was a pretty profound statement
right there
they're becoming virtual governments is
what they're becoming okay so that's
your story that we had with zuck
spending the security you were so
concerned about i'm glad we touched it
let's talk
about the every given ship that has been
sitting there
not being able to leave check this out
pretty crazy story on what's going on
with the ship
that we have parked there kai it's on
page three
so every given ship forbidden to leave
the suez canal until its owners pay up
to a billion dollars in compensation for
the chaos it caused business insider
story
egyptian authorities said that they
wouldn't release the massive ship which
was stuck in the source canal for almost
a week until its owners agreed to pay up
to a billion dollars in compensation
lieutenant general osama rabi who led
the suez canal authority said egyptian
authorities would demand a billion
dollars to cover the cost of
freeing the vessel the figure would
cover the expense of the equipment and
machinery used to clear the way in
damage to the canal itself
by the dredging uh while also
compensating about 800 people who work
to release the 200 000 ton ship
it would also fund the costs from
blocking the canal which ended up
causing an epic traffic jam of more than
400 ships on either side of the channel
fair or unfair
it's extremely unfair um unfair to
charge the billion like they should just
take the hit themselves it just makes
them seem
unsophisticated it's like a ransom it's
crazy one billion dollars how about
we're discussing this
some sort of settlement but meanwhile
the 25-man crew
is held hostage they haven't been
allowed to leave that ship even though
they are members of a union by the way
shout out to amazon's great success with
their union vote they can't get them off
the boat but i think it's just crazy it
makes you think i never want to go to
egypt
my god is if this is the way they do
business or or the suez canal how
unsophisticated this
this governance is of it i i'm shocked
by it it's sitting right there
just to come out and say a billion
dollars is irrational and crazy
well this was costing what 400 million
dollars an hour
as far as like how much it was costing
profits or
however i don't know how they calculated
that commerce commerce so yeah
i i agree that i actually i'm going to
take the other side of this thing i
think a billion dollars is a
a hefty yeah egypt if that was the
global economy that suffered from that
right yeah well egypt is the the country
that it all went down they want their
money bro they just you know
so you're supporting egypt by the way
they haven't been able to build that
ship either
all the time friends on this one by the
way shout out to our muslim friends out
there today is the first day of ramadan
and you know from a jew to a muslim
sitting with a christian
sitting with uh i don't know i don't
know
i don't know i don't know where you are
he's a christian christian you know just
shout out to all our people out there
like can't we all just get along
just like our friend um ronnie i agree
i agree so okay so you're sticking to
the bill
i think the billion dollars is uh
fair because if you are being urgent
about
going out there and bringing all these
the dredging the people
i i just don't know how they go about
doing it how do you come up with the
math to figure out would it be the ship
owner to pay for is it his fault whose
fault was it the win
is that because the cause of it then
that's going to cause an investigation
because a ship owner is going to say why
am i going to pay for this i didn't do
it i didn't cause the win i didn't call
everything that happened here yeah this
is your fault so there's so much great
area
you could have built out the dam more i
mean yeah damn hasn't been touched yeah
yeah that's pretty much the ours
yeah i agree so why why and what does
that money go to just do damages or to
build that but don't get me wrong
they did take a hit though there is a
hit taken but i would want to know what
caused it
if it's man-made or if it's nature if
it's nature why don't you sue god
send the bill to him see what's going to
if he's going to pay for it he might pay
hey the hard costs by the way are about
120 million for for the digging the
dragging the towing
the all that stuff is about 120 million
so to me a billion is exorbitant i mean
this is something how do you settle this
right away you don't hold a ship hostage
and say
pay a billion or you can't move on
there's 20 000
crates on there that they haven't been
able to unload that's affecting a lot of
people that paid for that that it's
supposed to be coming through
that's what insurance companies are for
those are the that's the that's what's
going to eventually pay the toll on this
anyway
so it seems like a number that kind of
made up like oh a billion
all right go with it there's no math
involved i think it's just pure
emotional you better not screw up the
next time you go through the sewers
canal man they are not playing no
i know you're planning on going there in
a few weeks so just take it easy with
yeah so
going to be it's going to be a fun trip
out there it's going to be a fun trip
out there
by the way he's kidding i don't want
people to think i'm going to suicidal
okay
adam it may go to iran before i go to
suez canal okay so let's talk about
new york raising income taxes something
that shocked the hell out of us i
couldn't believe new york would actually
raise income taxes
uh hence the sarcasm but let's take a
look at what new york did new york
raises income taxes on super wealthy
raising concerns among corporations
a morning brew story last week lawmakers
passed a budget that raised the personal
income tax
on individuals for over a million
dollars and introduces two new brackets
of those making
more than 5 million and 25 million can
you imagine you have a tax bracket for
people making over 25 million dollars a
year
the changes mean that the wealthiest new
york city residents will face the
highest combined local and state
personal income rate in the country
surpassing california new york
officially passed california interesting
so 250 business executives have sent a
letter to state lawmakers arguing that
the higher taxes would jeopardize new
york's recovery from the economic crisis
inflicted by covet 19
by sending high net worth people fleeing
meanwhile just three hours south of the
jetblue flight miami twitter
in chief mayor suarez is welcome in new
york's wealthy with a promise of zero
state income taxes and carbon
reservation which makes new york city
leaders including mayoral
candidates andrew yang and ray mcguire
anxious that that tax hike could lead to
a 1970s
corporate exodus when the city lost half
of its fortune 500 companies
and then keep going to the next story
very interesting new york city
wealthiest look to exit
as a state readies hefty tax increase
that's a cnbs story
it's different stories new york's top
business leaders are gearing up for
potential mass exit is
as common state lawmakers prepare to
raise their taxes with the state budget
set to increase the personal income tax
on the wealthiest new york or somewhere
in arizona okay we covered that
wealthy business leaders who have
historically resisted moving at least
some of their resources to florida
or other less less tax state uh
explained that they are now
seriously considering as working from
homes
becomes the norm allowing more
flexibility florida does not have a
personal okay so similar story
two different articles by the way you
know who just moved to florida palm
beach and bought a 83 million dollar
home
yeah just about an 83 million dollar
home and they're
tearing it down and donald trump jr
and kimberly got a place in jupiter for
9.6 million
they sold their house i think in uh
connecticut are they married or just
dating
they're not i i wouldn't know i wouldn't
know i think they're
i think they're just dating seriously
dating though but go ahead what do you
think about new york
any different opinions i mean we've been
following this story this is not a new
story i just love
shout out to swan guy mayor francis
suarez we we
hung out with him the other day uh we
were at the event this was literally one
week ago i believe
um and i just love how all roads leave
to florida
lead to florida and specifically miami i
love how he has now taken the new
moniker the tweeter in chief francis
suarez
so how can i help come on down to
florida the weather's fine
by the way some people still don't know
that valuetainment is in florida i get
that when do you go
well today video we're not saying why i
moved to florida i just went out
finally this morning yeah well about
time yeah finally so
we're in florida and it's just uh come
on down new york
you know the thing that just annoys me
is just the the level of
unsophistication and uncreativity that
these politicians have in these states i
mean you've got to make a a conscious
decision i'm going to live in new york
and i'm going to live in california i'm
just going to have to deal with it right
there's better alternatives and you look
at a state like florida and texas that
has no state income tax and they're
thriving
they are taxing less and it's working
and these
bozos just think we'll just keep adding
taxes and the lowest hanging
fruit is the rich people it's the
corporations it's people making 25
million or more so that's the easy
target
you go against the extra you know few
billion that you pump into the general
economy and it doesn't do anything
because the other story attached to this
is how they're giving away thirteen
thousand dollars to
undocumented immigrants or something in
new york as well which is staggering and
um
do you have that story in here because
that's right i'd like to go through
right above that story
what which page is it on same page
though you just read the same okay
there's page six okay let's go into that
as well because they all go together 2.1
billion dollars
for undocumented workers signals new
york's progressive shift this is a new
york times story which is the most
progressive newspaper out there saying
progressive shift after sweeping move
by lawmakers this week new york will now
offer one-time payments of up to fifteen
thousand six hundred dollars to
undocumented immigrants who lost work
during the pandemic
the effort a 2.1 billion dollar fund in
the state budget is by far the biggest
of its kind in the country and a sign
that the state shift towards
policies championed by progressive
democrats such as
aoc in the state of new york republicans
instantly criticized the measure
as out of touch at a time when many
other new yorkers were still struggling
while
some democrats from swings districts
upstate and on long island said
privately
that a publicly funded rescue program
for people are not in the country
legally would be wielded
as a uh as a
uh against cudgel against them in future
elections new york's
fund dwarfs a similar relief program
enacted in california where officials
set up a 75 million cash assistant
program last year and gave undocumented
immigrants a 500
one-time payment on a first-come
first-served basis this is fifteen
thousand
six hundred dollars yeah they probably
won't tax them either if you're okay
look adam do you support this
no hell no that's ridiculous this is
unfair look this is undocumented
immigrants these aren't
you know so if you're gonna if you're
gonna give a 500 payment to
you know somebody or stimulus to your
fellow americans cool i get it
fifteen thousand freaking dollars to
undocumented guys don't pay attention
how does that even
how is that even a good idea i would
love to get the other end of the
spectrum
it's unfair they lost their jobs how
come you don't they're not american
citizens what are we talking
about here okay adam you sound like a
conservative you saw like i said that's
wrong
no he's watching like a reasonable
person oh i sound like a wretched why
it's so
shocking oh senator you don't wanna you
don't wanna let the cat out the bag
center this guy flip-flops more than a
guy on a vacation
so um it's just absurd
it's just absurd and sometimes you know
to my fellow democrats out there
sometimes you need some tough love
just like you know if someone's a family
member they need some tough love
this is freaking absurd how does someone
even justify this to
to the aoc's out there to the de
blasio's out there whoever the hell's
running the show new york city
like this is ridiculous the 1974
exodus of what happened with fortune 500
companies
like listen you realize you have
documentation to know what happened in
the 1970s when a massive exodus took
place
how do you not see trends in new york
how do you not see it how do you not see
that that
is taking place rewarding people for
doing nothing is one of the stupidest
things you can possibly do as a
government
and it is hurting businesses huge like
in california i'll give you an example
you go to restaurants that are finally
able to open again
you know what their biggest problem is
wait staff support staff they can't find
people
because they cannot rehire the people
that used to work there because they're
making more money on unemployment
it doesn't make sense for them to go
back to work so good restaurants then
have to
go to a shrinking pool to try to find
qualified applicants that can handle
that they have to retrain them
they have to pay first they have to find
people that probably don't even have
experience as waiters and you see that
difference
you talk to restaurant owners it's a
huge huge problem this is just
so it's so stupid it almost makes you
wonder why democrats didn't think of it
sooner
right it's almost like a story you would
see in the onion and you're like oh okay
hilarious yeah exactly but it's not
fifteen thousand scariest buddy fifteen
thousand dollars and it's
normal and it's untaxed too right i mean
they won't even imagine that
you know what like some people are gonna
be like take away my green card give me
the money i'll be in i'll be illegal
i feel like they're gonna they're gonna
justify that by saying with payments
up to fifteen thousand dollars meaning
they might not get the whole thing they
might qualify for a thousand dollars
aoc is celebrating right now you'll see
sitting there saying we are making
new york more impressive be aoc for a
second
you know flip the script you're aoc yep
why does this make sense
why does this make sense some of the
things that you said is you like to
to research the other side just to kind
of get yourself a 100
socialistic philosophy okay this is this
is all we're going to take care of you
this is a what comes after this is when
you take care of undocumented
immigrants next comes if they live here
and they pay taxes they ought to be able
to vote as well
i mean you're leading to the direction
of wanting to allow undocumented
uh immigrants to be able to vote and
once that happens
forget about the anybody winning on the
right if that takes yeah but nobody's
winning on the right in new york anyway
so why is that such a i don't know i
think i think we're too quick to
think that america is going to be the
greatest country in the world forever
like this money is going to be here
forever and we can spend it because
money is going to be here forever
you listen you are not rich forever you
know how people retire and they're
sitting down the money and they're like
oh you know
i got my retirement a million dollars
how are you 65 dude you're gonna live to
90.
yeah a million dollars at 65 25 no no
you
25 years say you get three percent
interest on your million dollars that's
000 say social security sends you
another 20 grand that's 50 000
you you're going to be able to afford
that for the next 25 years and your
lifestyle has been 150
no you need 45 million so people think
money supply and success lasts forever
it doesn't
new york is getting cocky new york is
getting arrogant
new york is thinking nobody will leave
them because it's new york city the
financial capital
of the world they forget that many other
financial capitals of the world
lost their reputation due to exact kind
of policies
that new york is doing they got to be
reading what's going on in the news they
got to be saying
what's going on they're already leaving
that sound like well maybe we'll leave
already left
how do you how do you reason with
unreasonable human beings
but cuomo is the type of person that
seems reasonable yeah but
the only thing cuomo is thinking about
right now is to make sure he doesn't get
impeached what do you think he's almost
thinking about are you serious
cuomo wakes up every day with somebody
new coming out and saying he kissed me
on the cheek he did this he did that
every day he's got a different story
coming out i haven't heard many stories
in the last few weeks well
maybe they're happy because this past
maybe that's why you kind of got
silenced
by the the people around him say the
exact same thing that he's only
governing
to save himself i mean that's it that's
his main motivation most of the time
anyway especially now you're not more
powerful than
the the tribe of democrats and everybody
on the socialist side you are not more
powerful than them you just are not it's
that's
it's that's straight up you think you
are you're not no matter how many lives
you did
everybody loved you cuomo no that's not
how this thing works okay
last story i want to do here before we
wrap up is ron desantis why ron desantis
2024 stock is rising a wall street
journal story
desantis has burnished his brand with a
covenanting response that has enthused
the voters base of a former president
trump while in florida at least also
impressing the kind of moderate and
suburban
voters who turn away from mr trump in
2020 as the gop looks to rebuild after
losing a presidential election last year
that formula could give
mr desantis an advantage over rivals who
similarly are trying to forge
their own path in the shadow of trump
over the past year the santas rejected
the advice of most public health experts
and reopened the state's economy early
resisted mass mandates and other
restrictions and made florida one of the
most permissive
settings in the u.s he produced he
received praise from republicans on
scathing criticism
from democrats while sparring regularly
with the media practice that endeared
him
to fans and allies of trump thoughts you
know he's not a lightning rod
like trump is and if you're thinking
about 2024 the republicans have to find
some candidate that they maybe get a
little bit
of momentum behind trump came out the
other day and said i don't even know if
i'm going to run for president again and
if i do i won't say anything until 2022.
so he's really not really a factor right
now and desantis
is doing well the state's doing well um
he's likable
he's not hated by everybody on the left
yet
so we'll see um i don't know if that do
you think that's his intentions maybe to
write
the process they use with the finger to
show the similarities between him and
trump you know how trump would do the
finger thing well this is the wall
street journal they're
they're they're more right yeah they're
center right i i
i trust what the wall street journal has
to say well look florida for sure was
the big winner in the pandemic
okay texas you know arguably up there as
well
uh with uh governor abbott um who i
guess was polling around zero
at cpac and ron desantis was polling
pretty well but florida was the big
winner in the pandemic they did what
they hosted the super bowl they hosted
the nba bubble they've been trying to
get the olympics down here
so credit needs to go to the top he's
the governor he's in charge of florida
so
you know he made some magic happen um
but
in 20 in 2024 i don't think he stands a
chance
against the rock so there it is the
santas doesn't stand a chance against
the rock in 2024.
no interesting you think rock's running
in 2024
i i would guess maybe 20 i don't i don't
know how do you run in 2024 against if
you're going to be a democrat you can't
run
because you can't run against biden
let's not assume that biden's going to
be there
okay you are thinking i have a thousand
dollar bet that he's going to make
through this term so this thing's making
you money here with this
mission i got to tell you you got to
have like i'm not ready i'm not blue i'm
all about the green bay
but if you think about it the state of
florida is the capital of the republican
party now that you have the entire trump
family living here
right and you got a strong governor so
watch for him mario hernandez just gave
100 bucks and said the 15 000
seems excessive plus undocumented
immigrants do pay
taxes from sales to fit and don't get a
tax refund for
uh or very little well that's true but
they don't pay they don't pay income
taxes that's the difference
yeah that's the difference that's the
difference what we got there okay
anyways all right guys we're at the end
of it here if you enjoyed the podcast
smash that subscribe button
we're getting closer to 100 000 with pbd
podcast
it is a separate channel and if you
enjoyed it as well put that thumbs up
uh we are going to add the short clips
to our channel here soon
and this thursday i believe is it tom
ellsworth with us
well if if we can figure out a way to do
the tequila thing maybe we will do four
i don't know if we have the fourth my q
or not let's see what you can do between
now
and so don't have i think said that
gentlemen good to be on i had a good
time with you guys today real quick
congratulations on the dude i appreciate
that buddy thank you
to the loyal listeners that stayed with
us to get us at 3k
yes we respect you yes and shout out to
kai over there doing great research
and our bosnian friend out there who's
doing some awesome workouts
bosnian researchers phenomenal
by the way emmanuel
have a good one everybody take care bye
you